As the COVID-19 epidemic sweeps across the world,...
...it's been accompanied by a tsunami of misinformation.
Drink lemon and bicarbonate.
Oh my god.
Chloroquine.
Hold your breath over 10 seconds to check if your lung is healthy.
If you keep sipping hot water, that washes it down to your stomach.
At the time when reliable information is vital for public health,...
...fake news about COVID-19 might be spreading even faster than the facts.
We're not just fighting an epidemic.
We're fighting an infodemic.
Fake news spreads faster and more easily than this virus...
...and is just as dangerous.
Researchers across the globe are working...
...to understand how misinformation spreads,...
...and new models suggest that while the fight against fake news can seem hopeless,...
...it might not take too much effort to tip the balance.